I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Good morning. Good morning.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。早上好。早上好。
Good afternoon. Good evening. You're very peppy for such a serious subject. I am really excited about this episode. Everyone it's murder. Ugh! Dun-dun-dun. Season 6, episode 10, written by Daniel Chun and directed by Greg Daniels.
下午好。晚上好。对于这么严肃的主题，你未免也太有活力了。我对这一集真的超级兴奋。大家注意，这是一场谋杀案。呃！咚咚咚。第六季第10集，由丹尼尔·陈编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。
And we have a special treat this week for you for our summary. We do! Okay, so you guys, you know I have a big southern family. We're spread out between Louisiana and Texas and I know it's not Savannah, Georgia. But my sister, Billy Joe, has a great southern accent. And I asked her to read our summary today. And she did. Here it is.
这周我们为你们准备了一个特别的彩蛋总结。没错！好了，大家知道我有一个庞大的南方家族。我们的亲戚分布在路易斯安那州和得克萨斯州，我知道这里不是佐治亚州萨凡纳。但是我的妹妹比利·乔有着极好的南方口音。我请她来读我们今天的总结。她真的读了。给，就是这个。
I do declare there's been a murder. Michael attempts to distract his employees with a murder mystery party after everyone hears rumors that the company might be going bankrupt. Jim wants everyone to keep walking and is frustrated by Michael's game. Meanwhile, Andy attempts to ask Aaron out on a date. Angela, she nailed it! She nailed it! Jenna, I was so tickled by this.
我敢说发生了一起谋杀案。在听到公司可能要破产的传言后，迈克尔试图用一场谋杀之谜派对来分散员工的注意力。吉姆希望大家继续工作，对迈克尔的游戏感到沮丧。与此同时，安迪试图约亚伦出去约会。安吉拉，她太神了！她太神了！珍娜，我被逗得太开心了。
I knew I wanted someone in my family because this episode partly takes place in Savannah, Georgia. Yes. So I knew I would want someone from my southern family to give the summary ago. And thank you, Billy. Thank you, Billy, for giving it a shot. While she can do the summary any time, Ange. Billy Joe, did you hear that?
我知道我想让家里的某个人来读，因为这一集部分发生在佐治亚州萨凡纳。没错。所以我知道我会想让南方家族的人来试试这个总结。谢谢你，比利。谢谢你，比利，愿意尝试一下。虽然她随时都可以做总结，安吉。比利·乔，你听到这个了吗？
Right now she's like, no, no, no, no, no. Somewhere she's yelling. No, no, no. Well, let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one is all about our new writer for this episode, Daniel Chun. We know him as Danny. He started on the writing staff for season six. He was a supervising producer and this was his first script.
此刻她一定在想，不，不，不，不，不。她一定在某个地方大喊。不，不，不。好了，让我们进入快讯。快讯第一条是关于我们这一集的新编剧丹尼尔·陈。我们叫他丹尼。他从第六季开始加入编剧团队。他曾担任总制片人，这是他的第一个剧本。
Danny had previously written on The Simpsons for six years. I was able to get back in touch with him, which was so fun. And he told me that he knew a lot of the office writers socially, just through the comedy writing community. He knew BJ for a long time. He said that he loved being at The Simpsons, but he kind of felt like 80% of working on that show was just punching up jokes, unless you were the showrunner. So he didn't get to do a lot of long form writing there, I guess.
丹尼之前曾为《辛普森一家》写过六年剧本。我联系上了他，这太有趣了。他告诉我，他通过喜剧编剧圈在社交上认识了《办公室》的很多编剧。他认识BJ很长时间了。他说他很喜欢在《辛普森一家》工作，但他觉得在那部剧里80%的工作都只是润色笑话，除非你是剧集运作人。所以我想他在那里没有机会做太多长篇剧本创作。
He said he was really hungry for a different challenge. BJ had always been a big supporter of his writing and he showed Mindy and Paul some stuff that Danny had written just for fun on MySpace. Remember MySpace? Oh my God, yeah. He said that gives you a sense of how long ago this was. But the stuff he had written on MySpace got him a meeting. They brought him in and that's how he got hired to be one of our writers for season six.
他说他非常渴望接受不同的挑战。BJ一直是他的剧本的坚强后盾，他把丹尼在MySpace上随性写的东西拿给明迪和保罗看。还记得MySpace吗？哦天哪，记得。他说这能让你感受到那是多久以前的事了。但他在MySpace上写的东西给他赢得了一次会面机会。他们把他请了过去，这就是他被录用为我们第六季编剧的方式。
See guys, you never know. You never know. Yeah, all that stuff that you're writing, if it's a blog, if it's a vlog, I don't even know. You're creating it. All the logs out there. All of them. Someone could see it.
看吧各位，你永远不会知道。你永远不会知道。没错，你写的所有那些东西，不管是博客、视频博客，我都不知道。你在创造它。外面所有的“客”。所有的“客”。别人可能会看到。
Yes. So, fast fact number two, I was able to talk to Danny a little bit about the inspiration for this episode of Murder. What was it? He said this was a card on the wall. What did the card say? The card said, Michael makes everyone play a murder mystery game. It was one of the pitches they had come up with over the summer.
是的。所以，快讯第二条，我得以和丹尼稍微聊了聊这一集《谋杀》的灵感来源。那是什么？他说这是墙上的一张便签。便签上写了什么？便签上写着：迈克尔让每个人都玩谋杀之谜游戏。这是他们夏天想出的众多创意之一。
He also remembered a card that never got made. It was this. They go on a ski trip and someone makes a huge stain on the wall. Ew. I know, but he was pointing out like this is how simple a card could be. They picked this one and then they had to figure out how, why, what happens? How is this a whole episode? So on Mom Detectives, a card could be two ladies on a train with a succulent.
他还记得一张从未被采用的便签。是这个。他们去滑雪旅行，有人在墙上弄了一个大污渍。呃。我知道，但他指出这说明一张便签可以有多简单。他们挑中了这张，然后他们不得不弄清楚如何、为什么、发生了什么？这怎么能成为整整一集呢？所以在《妈妈侦探》里，一张便签可能就是两个带有多肉植物的女士在火车上。
Yes. And that has to be a whole episode. That's an episode. Yeah. Now you have to turn that into something. Yeah. Danny said they also, for season six, had all of these mini arcs that they were going to add to the season.
是的。而那必须成为整整一集。那是一集。对。现在你必须把那个变成点什么。对。丹尼说他们为第六季准备了所有这些准备加入这一季的迷你故事线。
Those are little stories that take place over several episodes. And one of those ideas was that Dunder Mifflin was going to go bankrupt. And another one was that Jim would get this co-manager position. That's already happened. But this episode of the murder mystery game, they thought it tied in really well with that mini arc of Dunder Mifflin going out of business. Oh, for sure. So there is a DVD commentary for this episode.
那些是在好几集中展开的小故事。其中一个想法是邓德米夫林将要破产。另一个想法是吉姆将获得这个联合经理的职位。这已经发生了。但这一集的谋杀之谜游戏，他们认为这与邓德米夫林即将倒闭的那个迷你故事线完美契合。哦，肯定的。所以这一集有一个DVD评论音轨。
Oh. It features Ellie Kemper, Danny Chun, and Greg Daniels. And they talked a little bit about this episode setting up three major arcs, like exactly what you're saying, the crumbling of Dunder Mifflin, the sale to Sabre, and Andy and Aaron. Yes. The Andy and Aaron. You're right.
哦。里面有艾莉·肯珀、丹尼尔·陈和格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他们稍微聊了聊这一集如何为三个主要故事线做铺垫，正如你所说的那样，邓德米夫林的分崩离析、向萨伯的出售，以及安迪和亚伦。是的。安迪和亚伦。你说得对。
That's another one. Danny also told me that the writers played one of these murder mystery games for research in the writer's room. He said they noticed that in all of the games, the people had silly pun names, so they knew they were going to have to do that. There was a CD with a narrator that would help you along. He said in the game they played, his character was a Frenchman. And so he was stumbling through a French accent while they were playing, and that kind of
那是另一个。丹尼还告诉我，为了做调研，编剧们在编剧室里玩了其中一个谋杀之谜游戏。他说他们注意到在所有的游戏中，人们都有荒谬的双关名字，所以他们知道他们也得这么做。里面有一张带有旁白解说的CD可以帮助你推进。他说在他们玩的游戏中，他的角色是一个法国人。所以他在玩的时候一直在用蹩脚的法国口音结结巴巴地说话，这差不多
gave them the idea that they should have a game where everybody has to have accents. He also said that they originally thought that this game could be murder in little Italy, but they were afraid that would feel too much like the Mafia episode. And so that's when they pitched the game be set in Savannah. Well Danny said mainly he just remembered feeling like the game was not that much fun. It involved a lot of acting. And so he thought about that, and he thought that's why people like Andy and Michael would like the game.
给了他们一个灵感，那就是他们应该搞一个所有人都必须带有口音的游戏。他还说他们最初以为这个游戏可以是“小意大利谋杀案”，但他们担心那样会太像黑手党那一集了。所以这就是他们把游戏背景设定在萨凡纳的原因。好吧，丹尼说他主要只记得当时觉得这个游戏没那么好玩。它涉及大量的表演。所以他想到了这一点，他认为这就是为什么安迪和迈克尔会喜欢这个游戏的原因。
I just really like how much playing this game in the writer's room informed them. You know? Yeah. Because Danny was like, I don't like playing this game. I don't like doing an accent, and it's too much acting. I feel like he now could write very well for Angela. And Stanley. Yeah.
我真的很喜欢在编剧室里玩这个游戏给他们带来了多少启发。你知道吗？对。因为丹尼觉得：我不喜欢玩这个游戏。我不喜欢模仿口音，而且表演成分太多了。我觉得他现在完全可以把安吉拉写得很好。还有斯坦利。对。
But he's like, somebody would like this, I guess, Andy and Michael. I thought this was an amazing episode. So Danny, my gosh, your first one out of the gate, home run. I really liked it too. All right. Fast fact number three, Angela, is a fan question from Megan H. and Edmonton, Alberta, Canada, who would like to know if either of us have ever done a murder mystery event, like in the show.
但他觉得：我想会有人喜欢这个的，比如安迪和迈克尔。我觉得这是一集精彩绝伦的节目。所以丹尼，天哪，你的处女作一炮而红，本垒打。我也非常喜欢。好了。快讯第三条，安吉拉，是来自加拿大艾伯塔省埃德蒙顿的梅根·H.的粉丝提问，她想知道我们俩是否曾经玩过像剧里那种谋杀之谜活动。
Great question. I actually have a story, Jenna. Do you have one? I do too. Okay. You go first. Oh, okay. I was once invited to a dinner party where they said there will be dinner, and then we
好问题。珍娜，我其实有个故事。你有吗？我也有。好吧。你先来。哦，好吧。我曾经被邀请去参加一个晚宴，他们说会有晚餐，然后我们
will be playing a game as a group. Did they say what the game was? No. Oh. And when I got there at dinner, the host explained the game while we ate our meal. Guess who the hosts were? Who? Oscar Nunez.
会作为一个群体玩一个游戏。他们说是什么游戏了吗？没有。哦。当我到达晚宴现场时，主宾在大家用餐时解释了这个游戏。你猜主宾是谁？谁？奥斯卡·努涅斯。
What? Yes, and his wife, Ursula. Oscar hosted you for a murder mystery game night? Yes. Was this before this episode or after? Before this episode. Oh, my gosh. So the game was called Mafia.
什么？是的，还有他的妻子厄休拉。奥斯卡请你去玩谋杀之谜游戏之夜？是的。这是这一集之前还是之后？这一集之前。哦，天哪。所以那个游戏叫“黑手党”。
Oh, yeah. This is really a popular game. Yes. This was like all the rage in Los Angeles for a very long time. I don't know if this went over the whole country, but people were crazy about this game. Crazy about it. And they had the rules. I was actually texting with Ursula yesterday.
哦，对。这真的是个很受欢迎的游戏。是的。这在洛杉矶风靡了很长一段时间。我不知道这是否火遍了全国，但人们对这个游戏简直疯狂。疯狂着迷。而且他们有规则。我昨天其实还在和厄休拉发信息。
I was like, Ursula, what did you guys call it? Because in my memory, they called it killer. And she goes, no, Ursula was called Mafia. Yes. And so there were about 10 of us at the dinner party. And there's a few different ways you can play this, but the way we played it was there was one Mafia, one killer, a detective, a doctor, and a narrator, and then you had the civilians. Okay.
我说：厄休拉，你们叫它什么来着？因为在我的记忆里，他们叫它“杀手”。她说：不，厄休拉叫“黑手党”。是的。所以那天晚上聚餐的大概有10个人左右。有几种不同的玩法，但我们的玩法是有一个黑手党、一个杀手、一个侦探、一个医生和一个旁白，然后剩下的就是平民。好吧。
And the narrator kind of moves it along. The narrators who knows who's who, right? Oh, okay. Because that seems like not as much fun of a part. It actually is. I've been the narrator before and it's kind of fun. Oh, okay. Go ahead.
旁白负责推动游戏进展。旁白知道谁是谁，对吧？哦，好吧。因为听起来那个角色好像没那么好玩。其实挺好玩的。我以前当过旁白，还挺有趣的。哦，好吧。你接着说。
I'm going to play Mafia, which I kind of can't believe because I'm a sucker for these games. I want us to do this. Oh my gosh, Ear Wolf Company party. We play Mafia. Have you guys played it? Sam, Cassie, have you played Mafia? No, I haven't, but I do remember the absolute stranglehold that it had over everybody for a while.
我要去玩“黑手党”，我简直不敢相信，因为我对这种游戏毫无抵抗力。我想让我们也玩这个。天哪，耳狼公司的派对。我们玩“黑手党”。你们玩过吗？萨姆、卡茜，你们玩过“黑手党”吗？不，我没玩过，但我确实记得它曾经对所有人产生的绝对统治力。
Oh, yeah. Wordle or animal crossing at that time. Yes. Everybody was playing it. So in Mafia, the game is divided into two phases, day and night. During the night, everyone closes their eyes and the narrator awakens each role. So the narrator starts with the Mafia person, lets them know who it is because in each round it's someone new, right?
哦，是的。就像那时的Wordle或者动物森友会。是的。每个人都在玩。所以在“黑手党”中，游戏分为两个阶段，白天和黑夜。在夜里，每个人都闭上眼睛，旁白唤醒每一个角色。所以旁白从黑手党人员开始，让他们知道是谁，因为每一轮都是新的人，对吧？
And as the Mafia person, the way you kill someone is you wink at them. So you have to be real sneaky. At least that's how we played it. And then the doctor can choose to save someone or not. And the civilians have to try to figure out because every time they awaken, someone is dead. Oh. Right?
作为黑手党人员，你杀人的方式是向他们眨眼。所以你必须非常隐蔽。至少我们是这么玩的。然后医生可以选择救或者不救某个人。平民必须设法弄清楚，因为每次他们醒来时，都有人死了。哦。对吧？
Because the Mafia person kills someone each time. So the civilians begin questioning each other and there's a detective role. But I imagine though also the Mafia person is, and the doctor, they're pretending, everyone's pretending to be a civilian. Yes. Right. Yes. And it's so much fun.
因为黑手党人员每次都会杀一个人。所以平民开始互相盘问，还有一个侦探角色。但我想黑手党人员和医生也是，他们在假装，所有人都假装自己是平民。是的。没错。是的。这太好玩了。
And one time I was the Mafia person and no one figured me out. Right? What does that say? It says you were very good at pretending to be a civilian. You're diabolical. It was really, really fun. But yes, I played a version of this murder mystery with Oscar in real life. Wow.
有一次我是黑手党人员，没有人看出是我。对吧？这说明了什么？说明你非常擅长假装平民。你太阴险了。真的非常非常有趣。但是是的，我在现实生活中和奥斯卡玩过这个谋杀之谜的版本。哇。
Before this episode. Before this episode. That's very cool. I know. Is that crazy? I did not have to wear a funny hat or have an accent, I should say. I guess you could have chosen to. Well it is very funny that you say that, Angela, because I did a mini deep dive on the murder
在这集之前。在这集之前。太酷了。我知道。是不是很疯狂？我不用戴滑稽的帽子，或者说不用带口音。我想你本来也可以选的。你这么说真好笑，安吉拉，因为我对谋杀
mystery game genre. And they believe that it began in the first half of the 19th century with a party game called Wink Murder. Oh. Yeah. One player is secretly selected as a murderer and they kill other players by winking at them. That's what we did.
之谜游戏流派做了一个微型深度调研。他们认为它始于19世纪上半叶的一个叫做“眨眼谋杀”的派对游戏。哦。对。一名玩家被秘密选为谋杀犯，他们通过向其他玩家眨眼来杀死他们。这就是我们玩的。
If you get killed, you have to count to five before you die. Yes. Right? Is this it? Yes. You have to give it away so you have to like make a moment of it. This is so weird. Is Mafia just based on Wink Murder?
如果你被杀了，你必须数到五才能死。对。没错。是这个吗？是的。你得把它表现出来，所以你得制造一个戏剧时刻。这太诡异了。难道“黑手党”只是基于“眨眼谋杀”吗？
So far it's sounding like it. I will say this, if you play Mafia with your friends and you're the murderer and you're not good at winking, oh no, I never thought of that. Like me. I think I'm good with one eye. You just winked at me great with both eyes. Did I really? Yeah, you did fine.
到目前为止听起来确实是这样的。我得说，如果你和朋友玩“黑手党”，而你是谋杀犯，又很不擅长眨眼，哦不，我从来没想过这一点。就像我一样。我觉得我用一只眼睛眨得挺好。你刚才两只眼睛一起向我眨得可好了。我真的吗？是的，你做得挺好。
Oh. Well, I'm sorry. I watched you closer this time. The right eye. You do regular wink with this eye and then the other eye, you go. I know. So I can wink in normal speed with one eye, but the other one is like bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
哦。好吧，抱歉。这次我更仔细地观察你了。右眼。你用这只眼正常眨眼，然后另一只眼，你就……。我知道。所以我可以用一只眼睛以正常速度眨眼，但另一只就像是：邦，邦，邦，邦。
Yeah. I can see you concentrating on it. To try to wink. Yeah. So you got to figure out what's your good eye. Well I have never played Mafia. I have never played a Murder Mystery game. Yeah.
是的。我能看出你在集中精力。努力眨眼。对。所以你得找出哪只才是你管用的眼睛。好吧，我从来没玩过“黑手党”。我从来没玩过谋杀之谜游戏。对。
What's your story? Well, it was an actor in Murder Mystery Dinner Theater. Come on. Yep. Is there any footage of that? Can I see any of that? I have a photo of myself in my crushed velvet gown. I played several parts in several different shows.
你的故事是什么？好吧，我曾是一名谋杀之谜晚餐剧场的演员。别这样。没错。有那段录像吗？我能看点那个吗？我有一张自己穿着压花天鹅绒礼服的照片。我在好几部不同的剧里演过好几个角色。
This was my very first paid live theater acting gig. I did it in St. Louis, Missouri at the Lemp Mansion. A bunch of people would come in. Wait, was it like an old mansion? Like a haunted sort of cool like old mansion? Yeah. And I even had a ghost encounter there. Come on.
这是我的第一份带薪的现场戏剧表演工作。我在密苏里州圣路易斯的莱姆普大厦做的。一堆人会进来。等等，那是一个像老宅子一样的地方吗？就像那种闹鬼的、很酷的老宅子？是的。我在那儿甚至还遇到过鬼。少来。
I was working there. I did. I did. I saw the Lavender Lady. Come on. I did. What is the Lavender Lady? I don't know.
我在那儿工作过。真的。我看到了薰衣草夫人。少来。真的。薰衣草夫人是谁？我不知道。
I didn't know who the Lavender Lady was, but I was in what was one of the rooms of the house that they designated for the actors to change in. And no one was supposed to come in there because that was our changing room. And I heard the door open behind me. And I looked up in the mirror in front of me and behind me by the door, I saw a woman. And I said, I'm sorry, you can't be in here. And when I turned around, there was nothing there, the Lavender Lady. So I was fired up.
我不知道薰衣草夫人是谁，但我当时在房子的其中一个房间里，那是指定给演员换衣服的房间。而且任何人都不应该进那间休息室，因为那是我们的更衣室。我听到身后的门开了。我照了照面前的镜子，看到门旁边的我身后站着一个女人。我说：不好意思，你不能进来。当我转过身时，那里什么都没有，是薰衣草夫人。所以我当时火冒三丈。
I went to the owner of the place and I said, listen, if you're going to give us a place to change our clothes, you need to make sure it's secure. A woman walked right into that room. And he said, no one was in that area. And I said, well, explain to me how this woman walked in. He said, what'd she look like? And I said, well, she was, I kind of tried to describe her. I was like, as I was describing her, I realized like, I was like, she was wearing a big hat
我去找那里的老板说：听着，如果你要给我们一个换衣服的地方，你得确保它是安全的。刚才有个女人直接走进了那个房间。他说：那个区域没有人。我说：好吧，那向我解释一下这个女人是怎么走进来的。他说：她长什么样？我说：嗯，她……我试图描述她的外貌。我一边描述一边意识到，我想：她戴着一顶大帽子
and like a dress and sort of, I realized I was describing an old timey lady. And then his face got all white and he was like, oh my gosh, you saw the Lavender Lady. But yeah, I'm out at that point. I'm buh-bye by dinner theater career. I'm gone. I have to go entertain folks. They're on their salad course. I've got to get out there and tell them a murder has happened.
和一件连衣裙，而且有点……我意识到我描述的是一个老派的淑女。然后他的脸刷地变白了，他说：哦天哪，你看到薰衣草夫人了。好吧，那一刻我直接不干了。我的晚餐剧场演艺生涯拜拜了。我走了。我得去招待观众了。他们正在吃沙拉呢。我得出去告诉他们发生了一起谋杀案。
Wow. Yeah. Oh my gosh, that's creepy. Yeah. Wow, you did dinner theater lady. You did theater while someone was like buttering a baguette. Well here's the thing. We did it between courses.
哇。是的。哦天哪，太诡异了。哇，你当过晚餐剧场演员。当有人在抹法式长棍面包时，你还在演戏。事情是这样的。我们是在上菜的间隙演的。
So we'd bring everybody in. We'd sit them down. They're getting their drinks. We're handing out slips of paper. It was our job during this mingle to find the people who seemed outgoing enough to play the major roles because you don't want to give- Wait, wait. The people eating dinner play a part?
所以我们会把大家领进来。让他们坐下。他们在喝饮料。我们发纸条。我们在人们社交闲聊时的任务是找出那些看起来足够外向、能扮演主要角色的人，因为你不想把……等等，等等。吃晚餐的人要扮演角色？
Oh yes. Everybody gets a part. Everybody has a funny name. Someone in the room is the murderer. Oh, I didn't realize that. I thought you were performing a murder mystery while people ate dinner and watched you. No. Interactive improvisation slash scripted.
哦，是的。每个人都有角色。每个人都有一个滑稽的名字。房间里有个人是凶手。哦，我没意识到。我还以为是人们一边吃饭一边看你们表演谋杀之谜呢。不是。互动即兴表演结合剧本。
We had jokes. We had to keep people kind of on the plot, but you'd walk people to their table, waiters giving them a drink, you're hobnobbing with them in character, and you find the people that seem like they can play the different roles, and then you've got these slips of paper and you hand it to them, and then later you'd be like, where's Bobby Oylton? Bobby Oylton? Oh yes, I saw you when you came in. Bobby, what do you have to say for yourself?
我们有笑话。我们得让大家差不多跟着剧情走，但你要把大家带到桌子旁，侍者给他们端饮料，你以角色的身份和他们套近乎，然后你找出那些看起来能胜任不同角色的人，接着你拿着这些纸条递给他们，后来你就会说：鲍比·奥尔顿在哪儿？鲍比·奥尔顿？哦，是的，我看见你进来了。鲍比，你有什么要为自己辩解的吗？
And then he has to read off of his little slip of paper. You are Michael Scott. Yes, I sort of was. You are Caleb Crotad. I was sort of Caleb Crotad, yeah. Wow. Yeah, so I did that for two years, but I got 50 bucks a night. That was like good money for acting, for doing what I loved.
然后他得照着他的小纸条念。你是迈克尔·斯科特。是的，我差不多就是。你是卡利布·克罗塔德。我差不多就是卡利布·克罗塔德，对。哇。是的，我干了两年，一晚能赚50块大洋。对于演戏、做自己热爱的事来说，那算是不错的收入了。
I need mom detectives to go to a murder mystery dinner theater, put it on a card, Jenna. Yeah, we should investigate the lavender lady sighting. Yes. We'll get to the bottom of it. We will, but we'll have to be in character where outfits. Yes, because we'll pretend like we're part of the dinner theater. We'll pretend we're part of the show. My God, it writes itself.
我需要让《妈妈侦探》去参加一次谋杀之谜晚餐剧场，把它写进便签里，珍娜。对，我们应该调查一下薰衣草夫人的目击事件。是的。我们会查个水落石出的。我们会去的，但我们得穿着戏服保持角色状态。对，因为我们要假装自己是晚餐剧场的一部分。我们要假装自己是演出的一部分。天哪，这剧本自己都会写了。
My God. If I see this on TV one day, I'm gonna be so pissed. I'm gonna kick someone's ass if it's not you and I. I know. Kickin' some butts. All right, let's take a break and call our agents. We're back and today only Dwight Schrute presents this year in martial arts, colon updates, advancements, and et cetera.
天哪。如果有一天我在电视上看到这个，我会气死的。如果主角不是你和我，我非得踢某人的屁股不可。我知道。踢他们屁股。好了，让我们休息一下，给经纪人打个电话。我们回来了，今天只有德怀特·施鲁特为您带来今年武术更新、进展等内容的盘点。
Yes, like Jim said, there's always lots of changes to the 1,000-year-old martial arts traditions. Dwight's gonna start with Phyllis. I clock some moves. Phyllis charges Dwight with what looks to be a two-finger eye jab. Dwight stops her with an arm block that I guess would have broken her arm and then he's gonna flip her over. Yeah, he tries to engage Kevin, Kevin's a big no.
是的，就像吉姆说的，拥有千年历史的武术传统总是有很多变化。德怀特将从菲利斯开始。我捕捉到了一些招式。菲利斯向德怀特发起攻击，看起来像是双指戳眼。德怀特用手臂格挡挡住了她，我猜这本会折断她的手臂，然后他要把她凌空翻摔过去。对，他试图与凯文过招，凯文直接拒绝。
And all of this is gonna lead to Dwight fighting himself. Yes. I'd like to point out in this scene at 39 seconds, Meredith is wearing the designer sweater vest again. I clocked that too. I mean, I feel like this is some sort of personal trolling of me. Well I have a few tidbits about this cold open. Oh, really?
所有这一切最终将导致德怀特与自己打斗。是的。我想指出这一中39秒的场景中，梅雷迪思又穿着那件设计师毛衣背心了。我也注意到了。我是说，我觉得这某种程度上是对我的个人恶搞。不过我关于这个冷场白有一些小八卦。哦，真的吗？
I have some as well. Well I'll start by saying we got a lot of mail of people asking if Dwight's self-fight was choreographed. And I would like to tell you guys that was all Rainn Wilson. Bravo, Rainn! Yes, he came up with all of those moves based on descriptions in the script. We did have our stunt coordinator, Eric Solke, on board for the day just to make sure that Rainn didn't actually hurt himself.
我也有一些。好吧，我先说，我们收到了很多信件，人们询问德怀特的自我打斗动作是否是编排好的。我想告诉大家，那全都是雷恩·威尔逊自己发挥的。雷恩，好样的！是的，他根据剧本中的描述想出了所有这些动作。我们确实请来了特技统筹埃里克·索尔克在现场待了一天，以确保雷恩不会真的弄伤自己。
Well in the DVD commentary, Danny shared that the original version of this cold open ended with Dwight and Michael kicking each other in the groin. Oh, yeah. But instead they went with a pitch from Jen Salata where Dwight fights himself instead. It still ends with Dwight punching himself in the groin, but it was originally scripted to be a self-kick in the groin. It said this. How do you kick yourself in the groin?
在DVD评论音轨中，丹尼分享说，这个冷场白的最初版本结尾是德怀特和迈克尔互相踢对方的下体。哦，对。但他们最后采用了詹·萨拉塔的创意，改成了德怀特跟自己打斗。结尾依然是德怀特朝自己的下体挥拳，但最初剧本设定的是自己踢自己的下体。上面是这么写的。你怎么能自己踢到自己的下体？
Exactly. Yeah. Here's what the script said, quote, Dwight snaps his leg up and kicks himself in the balls. Dwight's face shows equally the pain of the kick and the pride of winning. That's so great. During the day, they realized there was no way for Rainn to self-kick himself in the balls, that it was just sort of physically impossible.
没错。是的。剧本上是这么写的，引用：“德怀特猛地抬起腿，踢了自己的蛋蛋。德怀特的脸上既流露出挨踢的痛苦，又流露出获胜的自豪。”太棒了。在拍摄当天，他们意识到雷恩根本不可能自己踢到自己的蛋蛋，那在生理上几乎是不可能的。
However, Danny said in an interview that Greg was convinced there was a way to do it if maybe they could attach a strap to Rainn's leg that would help sort of hoist it up somehow. He even sketched it out on the back of his script, which is a very Greg move. Can't you see Greg turning a script over and sketching out the self-groin kick strap? Here's how it works. Here's the mechanics. I want that sketch and I want it in a frame. Right?
然而，丹尼在一次采访中说，格雷格坚信有办法做到这一点，也许他们可以给雷恩的腿绑上一条带子，以某种方式把它吊起来。他甚至直接画在了剧本的背面，这非常符合格雷格的风格。难道你想象不出格雷格把剧本翻过来，草图画出自我下体踢绑带的样子吗？事情是这样的。原理是这样的。我想要那张草图，而且我要把它装进框里。对吧？
Where is that sketch? In the end, obviously, this was not happening, so they had Rainn punch himself in the groin. Greg shared that he really enjoyed directing the cold open and the tag for this episode because they were like many action movies, or the closest thing our show got to, little action sequences. And Jenna Alley shared something she said the cold open was filmed the morning of the Emmys. Oh, so after Rainn beat himself up, he had to go to the Emmys?
那张草图在哪儿？最终，显然这行不通，所以他们让雷恩自己朝下体挥了一拳。格雷格分享说，他真的很享受执导这一集的冷场白和尾声，因为它们就像微型动作片，或者说是我们剧集最接近的那种小型动作序列。珍娜·阿利分享说，她听说这个冷场白是在艾美奖那天早上拍摄的。哦，所以雷恩把自己暴揍了一顿之后，还得去参加艾美奖？
We all did. Wow. We worked that day. We have shared this before that many times we worked right up until an event and we would have to get ready at the set. Yeah. And the Emmys were traditionally on a Monday night. Yeah.
我们都去了。哇。我们那天工作了。我们之前分享过很多次，很多时候我们工作到活动开始前夕，然后不得不直接在片场化妆准备。是的。而且艾美奖传统上是在周一晚上举行。是的。
Which was rough because it would be like the beginning of your work week. Oh, and you'd be wrecked for the whole rest of the week. Wow. We worked this day and then we went to the Emmys. Oh, one last thing. I have a Dwight Flyer account. Oh. Because clearly you need to have multiple Flyers for your year in martial art update.
这太难熬了，因为感觉像是你工作周的刚开始。哦，而且你接下来的一整周都会废掉。哇。我们那天工作了，然后就去了艾美奖。哦，还有最后一件事。我有一个德怀特的“传单”道具。哦。因为显然你的武术年度更新需要有多个传单。
We have one on each of Jim's class walls and we have one on the door by accounting. Three in view during the whole cold open. I don't know about the rest of the bullpen. Or the kitchen. Or the break room. I know. I'm sure they're everywhere. They're not there for the rest of the episode, but there's three visible for the cold open.
吉姆的每面隔断墙上都有一个，会计部门旁边的门上有一个。整个冷场白期间视野里能看到三个。不知道办公区其他地方有没有。或者厨房。或者休息室。我知道。我敢肯定到处都是。整集剩下的时间里它们不在了，但在冷场白期间有三个是清晰可见的。
Well, now we're going to get into this episode. It opens with some weird banter between Michael and Andy about sculpting standup comedy. And it's interrupted by Dwight receiving an email. And Michael's like, you need to be more specific. I get like eight emails a day. Eight, Jenna. He gets eight. It's really weird that before we started recording today, we were discussing our email
好吧，现在我们要进入这一集了。开场是迈克尔和安迪之间关于雕刻单口喜剧的一些奇怪闲聊。然后被德怀特收到的一封电子邮件打断了。迈克尔说：你需要说得更具体点。我一天能收到大约八封邮件。八封，珍娜。他收到八封。真奇怪，在我们今天开始录音前，我们还在讨论我们的电子邮件
inboxes. Yeah. So guys, Sam and Jenna are really tidy about their email inbox like they get to zero. And then they asked me what my inbox said and my inbox says 1,582. And Sam and I are still processing that and we're, it gave you like hives per minute. Yeah. We're having a hard time. I don't mean this as an attack, but the way you live is chaos.
收件箱。是的。所以各位，萨姆和珍娜对她们的电子邮件收件箱非常整洁，她们能清空到零。然后她们问我的收件箱是多少，我的收件箱显示是1582。而萨姆和我还在消化这个数字，我们……这每分钟都能让你起荨麻疹。是的。我们快应付不过来了。我不是故意针对你，但你的生活方式简直是一团糟。
Sam's at zero right now. I'm at 10 unread emails. Actually do you remember in the break, there was a great Jenna moment where you were looking for an email and you couldn't find it and Jenna goes, oh, I'm sorry. Can you not? Yeah. I was like, oh, you can't find the email I sent you. I think I sent it on Monday or Tuesday.
萨姆现在是零。我有10封未读邮件。其实你还记得在茶歇时，有一个很棒的珍娜时刻，当时你在找一封邮件却找不到，珍娜说：哦，不好意思。你能别这样吗？对。我就像是在说：哦，你找不到我发给你的邮件了。我想我是周一或周二发的。
Well, I got a few emails since I last checked and now I'm 1,583. See, you do what Lee does, which is if you can tell that it's something you don't need to read, like it's, I don't know, an ad or something, you don't delete it. You just skip it. Yeah. And then it stays unread. Yes. I delete those.
好吧，自从我上次检查后我又收到了几封邮件，现在我是1583了。看吧，你做的事和李一样，那就是如果你能看出那是什么不需要读的东西，比如广告什么的，你就不删它。你直接跳过它。是的。然后它就一直保持未读状态。对。我把那些都删了。
I don't want that cluttering me. No, you do it right. That's the way you should do it. But if it doesn't bother you, then you're not doing it wrong. It would bother me if I did it your way. Well, Michael only gets eight, so I guess he's not super stressed out. I guess he's not. The email that Dwight is talking about is from David Wallace and it is referring to
我可不想让它们搞乱我的视线。不，你做得对。这才是你应该做的方式。但如果这不困扰你，那你就没做错。如果按你的方式来，我会觉得困扰。好吧，迈克尔只收到八封，所以我想他压力不是很大。我想他确实不大。德怀特在谈论的那封邮件来自大卫·华尔斯，它提到的是
an article in the journal. I mean the wall, as Michael calls it. Yeah. Oh, the wall. Right? Oscar finds the article, but in order to read it, you have to pay an extra $1.99 to get past the paywall. Danny shared that they spent like five hours researching the rules of the Wall Street Journal's
《华尔街日报》上的一篇文章。我是指那堵墙，正如迈克尔所说的那样。是的。哦，那堵墙。对吧？奥斯卡找到了这篇文章，但为了阅读它，你必须额外支付1.99美元才能突破付费墙。丹尼分享说，他们花了大约五个小时研究当时《华尔街日报》付费墙的规则。
paywall at that time. He said, apparently, if you're referencing a specific publication, you cannot make up a fact like that that's not true. Oh, so at that time, that was the rule of the paywall. Interesting. Why did it take five hours to get that information? I think they just had to get it correctly, and Jenna, they didn't have the Google back then.
他说，显然，如果你在引用一个特定的出版物，你就不能编造一个并非事实的事实。哦，所以当时付费墙的规则就是这样的。真有趣。为什么获取这个信息花了五个小时？我想他们只是必须弄对，而且珍娜，那时候他们还没有谷歌。
They had Google back then. It was like 2009. They didn't have the same search engines we had. 100% they did. How old do you think Google is? It's new. Google is new. I'm going to Google, when did Google start?
那时候他们有谷歌。那是2009年左右。他们可没有我们现在用的那些搜索引擎。100%有。你觉得谷歌有多老？它很新。谷歌很新。我要去谷歌一下，谷歌是什么时候创办的？
Well, I don't know why it took them five hours, but that's what he said on the DVD commentary. They had to be thorough, Jenna. What were you Googling in 2009? Don't put this on us. I'm not saying you, I'm saying people listening. Hold on. What did you Google in 2009? Google started September 4th, 1998, but their search engine, I'm going to get more specific.
好吧，我不知道为什么花了他们五个小时，但这是他在DVD评论音轨里说的。他们必须做到严谨，珍娜。你在2009年用谷歌搜什么？别把这推给我们。我不是说你，我是说听众。等等。你在2009年谷歌了什么？谷歌创办于1998年9月4日，但他们的搜索引擎，我要说得更具体点。
When did the Google search engine really come into effect? Not really come into effect. When did people start using the Google search engine? 1998. It really became popular around 2000. Thank you, Sam. I don't believe it. No one was Googling until like two years ago.
谷歌搜索引擎是什么时候真正投入使用的？不是真正投入使用。人们是什么时候开始使用谷歌搜索引擎的？1998年。它真正流行起来大约是在2000年左右。谢谢你，萨姆。我不信。直到大概两年前才有人在用谷歌。
Okay, everyone and I discovered Google a couple of years ago. Listen, I don't know why it took them five hours, but they clearly had to get it right. Maybe they had to get on the phone with someone. I'm not judging our writers, Jenna. I just thought it was a long time. Well, Jenna's judging you guys. Here's what I want to point out about this scene. As we're all gathered around the computer and everybody's reading this article off
好吧，我和大家都说我是前几年才发现谷歌的。听着，我不知道为什么花了他们五个小时，但他们显然必须弄对。也许他们不得不给某人打电话。我可没有评判我们的编剧，珍娜。我只是觉得时间有点长。好吧，珍娜在评判你们呢。这就是我想在这个场景中指出的地方。当我们全部聚集在电脑周围，大家都在读奥斯卡电脑上的这篇文章时，我们得知邓德米夫林可能要——我想——负债、破产、申请破产保护了。
of Oscar's computer, we're learning that Dunder Mifflin might be, I guess, going into debt, going under, filing for bankruptcy. Yeah. Angela, this entire scene, you are blocking me. You cannot see my face in this scene because you're standing directly in front of me. And then finally, you move out of the way and John blocks me. Did you take a picture? Yes, I did.
是的。安吉拉，在这个整场戏中，你都在挡着我。在这个场景里你根本看不到我的脸，因为你直接站在我前面。然后最后你终于让开时，约翰又挡住了我。你拍照了吗？是的，我拍了。
It was so funny to me because one of you is blocking me the whole time. We talked that morning and we were like, today is the day, John. You and I, I'm going to wear my three inch heels and I'm going to make sure I block that shot. Here, I put them all together. We really are. Why didn't anyone say anything? I don't know.
我觉得太搞笑了，因为你们俩总有一个人在挡着我。那天早上我们聊天时还说：今天就是今天，约翰。你和我，我要穿上我三英寸的高跟鞋，确保我把那个镜头挡得死死的。给，我把它们都拼在一起了。我们真的是这样。为什么当时没有人说点什么？我不知道。
So we don't know how Pam feels about this article because we can never see her. You can't see her face. Sorry. I rarely was able to block anyone. Personal victory, I guess. I know. Well, what's funny is they all stop at the $1.99. They're like, oh, I guess we're not going to know what really happens with the company.
所以我们不知道帕姆对这篇文章有何感想，因为我们永远看不到她。你看不到她的脸。抱歉。我极少能挡住任何人。这算是个人的小胜利吧。我知道。好吧，有趣的是他们都在1.99美元那里停下了。他们说：哦，看来我们不会知道公司到底怎么了。
And then Jim enters in his information. Yes. This sends Michael on a spiral and he calls David Wallace. David's in a meeting. I was curious about two moments in this scene. Okay. One was I was wondering if Steve improvised the way he said, you should spy on him. Wouldn't that be so hilarious?
然后吉姆输入了他的信息。是的。这让迈克尔情绪彻底失控，他给大卫·华尔斯打电话。大卫正在开会。我对这个场景中的两个时刻很好奇。好吧。一个是我想知道史蒂夫是不是即兴说出那句：“你应该监视他。”难道不是很搞笑吗？
Okay. I was like, did they tell Steve to say it like that? I went to the script and it said on that line in parentheses, valley girl. Oh, yeah. So they did give him sort of a line read. Yes. The other thing I was curious about was the line in the script when Michael says, catch you on the flippity flip.
好吧。当时我在想：他们是让史蒂夫那么说的吗？我翻了剧本，那句台词后面的括号里写着：山谷女孩。哦，是的。所以他们确实给他规定了一种台词念法。是的。我好奇的另一件事是剧本里迈克尔说的那句：“回头见，帅气的飞扑（catch you on the flippity flip）”。
I was like, that sounds like something Steve would improvise. No. So that line was in the script too. And Danny shared on the DVD commentary that Gene Stepnitsky actually pitched catch you on the flippity flip for a different episode and the writers loved it, but it didn't make it in. So they kept trying to get this line in episode after episode and they finally got it in. Well, you know, when Michael goes to the bathroom and he's been vomiting, but then he
我当时想：这听起来像是史蒂夫会即兴发挥的东西。不是的。所以那句台词也在剧本里。丹尼在DVD评论音轨中分享说，吉恩·斯普尼茨基其实为另一集构思了这句“catch you on the flippity flip”，编剧们非常喜欢，但当时没能用上。所以他们一直在试图一集又一集地把这句台词塞进去，最后终于成功加进去了。好吧，你知道的，当迈克尔去卫生间呕吐过后，他又
tries to tell Kevin he was just pooping. We had a fan question from Kelly C in Michigan. Who wrote the line, just poop and you know how I be. That was Danny. Danny said it's one of the lines he's most proud of. It's a great line. Oh, I also wanted to say one more thing, Angela. Back in the office when Michael calls and tries to get in touch with David Wallace, once again,
试图告诉凯文他只是去拉大便。我们收到了来自密歇根州凯利·C的粉丝提问。是谁写了那句“只是大便，你知道我平时怎么样的”。那是丹尼。丹尼说这是他最引以为傲的台词之一。这台词太棒了。哦，我还想说一件事，安吉拉。回到办公室里，当迈克尔打电话试图联系大卫·华尔斯时，再次地，
we had Suzanne Watson as the voice of David's assistant, Stephanie, and she's always great. So great. So in the script, Jenna, they built in more scenes to show Michael really spiraling. You know, he calls David, he vomits in the bathroom. He also just starts pacing in front of Aaron's reception, waiting for the phone call, waiting to see if she signals him that someone's calling. It's so funny. I want to play it for you.
我们有苏珊·沃森担任大卫助理斯蒂芬妮的声音，她一直都很棒。太棒了。所以在剧本里，珍娜，他们加入了更多场景来展现迈克尔的彻底失控。你知道的，他给大卫打电话，在卫生间呕吐。他还在亚伦的前台前来回踱步，等待电话，等着看她是否给自己打手势说有人来电话了。太搞笑了。我想放给你们听听。
It's in the deleted scenes. The first part I'm calling Michael is pissed. If it's not for me, don't make it look like it's for me. Okay. I'm sorry. Because I'm going to sh** my pants. Okay. I'm sorry.
这在被删减片段里。第一部分，打电话的迈克尔气急败坏。如果不是找我的，别搞得像找我一样。好的。我很抱歉。因为我快要拉裤子里了。好吧。我很抱歉。
It's my fault. Michael, I'm sorry before that I did not know what you were talking about. Don't. Okay. Do you want anything? Don't even talk. Don't even talk to me. Okay.
是我的错。迈克尔，我之前很抱歉，我不知道你在说什么。别这样。好吧。你想要什么吗？别说话。甚至别跟我说话。好吧。
All right. If they do call. Don't. Only if they call me, then talk to me. If it's anything else, or if you want to apologize to me for calling me when they weren't calling, then don't do that. All right. Do you understand?
好了。如果他们真的打电话来。别这样。只有他们打电话给我时，你才跟我说话。如果是其他任何事，或者如果你想为他们没打电话却叫我而向我道歉，那就别做那些。好了。你明白吗？
You're very, very nice, but you're really, you're, you're kind of pissing me off. Okay. Sorry. Did she laugh at the end? No. I thought she lied. I thought she said sorry. So her sorry looks like she's about to laugh, but then she turns it into like a cry.
你人非常好，但你真的很……你有点把我惹毛了。好吧。抱歉。她最后笑了吗？没有。我觉得她没笑。我觉得她说的是抱歉。所以她的道歉看起来像是要笑出来，但接着她把它转变成了一种快哭出来的表情。
And then poor Aaron, she's so confused by Michael, it continues and you've got to hear it. Don't cry. Don't cry. Please. Don't cry. Everybody's sort of high strong. So.
然后可怜的亚伦，她被迈克尔搞得一头雾水，这种情况还在继续，你们必须听听。别哭。别哭。求你了。别哭。大家都有点高度紧张。所以。
Okay. Chalk it up to that. We're all in it together. Well, don't laugh either. Just don't cry and don't laugh. Good. All right. It's such a funny moment.
好吧。归咎于这个吧。我们都在一条船上。好吧，也别笑。就是别哭也别笑。好。好吧。真是个搞笑的时刻。
Oh my gosh. I love the dynamic between the, those two, they really did a good job of creating a different dynamic than what Pam and Michael had. Yeah. I mean, she so earnestly wants to help him. She so earnestly wants to be liked by him. Yeah. And Michael with Pam, it's the reverse Michael wants to be in Pam's life.
哦天哪。我喜欢这两个人之间的化学反应，他们真的很出色，创造了一种不同于帕姆和迈克尔之间的化学反应。是的。我是说，她那么真诚地想要帮助他。她那么真诚地想要获得他的喜爱。是的。而迈克尔对帕姆则是反过来的，迈克尔想要融入帕姆的生活。
Yes. Oh, well, instead of all that, he's going to go into his office and play the Sean Mullins song lullaby. I found out from Randy Cordray that it cost us $45,000 to have this song in the show, to have this clip. Well, I have a background catch at five minutes, 29 seconds. Michael says he needs more Mullins and he hits the volume button on his keyboard repeatedly. Okay.
是的。哦，好吧，取代这一切的是，他要走进办公室去播放肖恩·马林的歌曲《摇篮曲》。我从兰迪·科德雷那里得知，这首歌在剧中出现、拥有这个片段花掉了我们45,000美元。好吧，我在5分29秒处有一个背景穿帮。迈克尔说他需要更多的马林，然后他反复按下键盘上的音量键。好吧。
Greg shared that they worked really hard in editing to get that sound to match Steve hitting the keyboard and Danny shared that after the episode aired, the comment boards were full of people saying that that was a Mac sound and Michael is using a PC. Oh my gosh. Is that funny? Oh, wow. They picked the wrong volume up sound. Well, Jim's going to come in during all of this.
格雷格分享说，他们在剪辑时付出了很多努力，才让那个声音与史蒂夫敲击键盘的动作匹配起来，丹尼则分享说，这一集播出后，评论区到处都是人说那是Mac电脑的声音，而迈克尔用的是PC。哦天哪。是不是很好笑？哦，哇。他们选错了调高音量的声音。好吧，这一切发生时吉姆进来了。
He's like, Michael, you have to pull it together. Like basically you're saying you're our leader and if you're freaking out, it's freaking out everyone. We need to just make this a normal day. What's on the agenda? Michael's like, well, we're supposed to have a staff meeting and Jim's like, great, everyone in the conference room. Have we ever seen Jim so excited to go into the conference room before?
他说：迈克尔，你得振作起来。基本上就是说你是我们的领导，如果你吓坏了，大家就全被吓坏了。我们需要把这当成平常的一天。日程上有什么？迈克尔说：嗯，我们本来应该开个员工会议的。吉姆说：太好了，所有人去会议室。我们以前见过吉姆这么兴奋地进会议室吗？
No, but he says he only slacks off when things are good. So I guess, you know, when the hits the fan, he becomes very professional. It's so funny because I feel like people would be equally freaked out by Jim suddenly having a work ethic. They'd be like, uh-oh. Absolutely. Uh-oh. What's happening?
没有，但他说他只有在一切顺利时才会偷懒。所以我想，你知道的，当麻烦来临时，他变得非常专业。这太搞笑了，因为我觉得大家如果看到吉姆突然有了职业道德，同样会被吓坏的。他们会觉得：呃哦。绝对会。呃哦。发生什么事了？
Stuff is bad. Jim wants to work. Yeah. Mom is getting serious. What's going on? Exactly. In the conference room, Jim addresses the group at five minutes, 56 seconds, Ryan is wearing glasses.
情况很糟。吉姆想工作。是的。妈妈变得严肃起来。怎么回事？没错。在会议室里，吉姆在五分五十六秒时向大家发表讲话，瑞恩戴着眼镜。
That was my big takeaway. Ryan is wearing glasses and everyone's in the conference room, but Kelly. Where's Kelly? Where is Kelly? Let me tell you, she's only in one scene this entire episode. What was she doing? Where was Mindy? I don't know.
那是我的最大收获。瑞恩戴着眼镜，每个人都在会议室里，除了凯利。凯利呢？凯利在哪里？我告诉你们吧，她整集只有一场戏。她在干什么？明迪去哪儿了？我不知道。
Michael has to leave the conference room to take a phone call and Dwight has one of my favorite lines in the episode. What is it? He says, he needs me. Seat saved infinity. Our kids saved seats. They're still in that phase of their life or like, I want that seat. That's my seat.
迈克尔不得不离开会议室去接电话，而德怀特说出了这集里我最喜欢的台词之一。是什么？他说，他需要我。占座无限。我们的孩子占了座。他们还处于人生的那个阶段，比如，我想要那个座位。那是我的座位。
Seat saved infinity. Dwight came to play. Well, Michael's going to come back. His phone call was bad news, Angela. Yeah. Very bad news. There's been a murder in Savannah. And that was the end of the act break.
占座无限。德怀特来真的了。好吧，迈克尔会回来的。他的电话是个坏消息，安吉拉。是的。非常坏的消息。萨凡纳发生了一起谋杀案。那是幕间休息的结束。
It was supposed to be. They were supposed to go to commercial. And then when they were editing, they thought that would be stressful. They thought it would be mean also to the audience. But instead we have this Michael talking head where we also see him going through his closet. He's looking for something. His office armoire. Yes.
本该如此的。他们本该进广告的。然后在剪辑时，他们觉得那样会很有压力。他们觉得对观众来说也太刻薄了。但取而代之的是，我们看到了迈克尔的单人采访，同时我们还看到他在翻找自己的衣橱。他在找东西。他的办公室大衣柜。是的。
There are many games inside and we realize there has not been a real murder. But we're going to play a murder mystery game. Yes. Because Michael thinks games help distract you in stressful situations. Yes. Did you see the games in his armoire? I did. Let's read him off.
里面有很多游戏，我们意识到并没有发生真正的谋杀。但我们要玩一个谋杀之谜游戏。是的。因为迈克尔认为游戏有助于在压力大的情况下分散注意力。是的。你看到他衣橱里的游戏了吗？我看到了。我们念出来吧。
All right. I don't know if we wrote him in the same order. Well you do one. I'll do one. All right. Connect four. Stratego. Operation.
好吧。我不知道我们写的顺序是不是一样的。那你做一个。我做一个。好吧。四子棋。战国风云。疯狂医生。
Trouble. Sorry. Risk. That's it. That's what I had. Me too. Well the game he brings in to the conference room is called Bells, Bourbon and Bullets, a murder mystery dinner party game.
麻烦。抱歉。风险。就是这样。这就是我有的。我也是。好吧，他带进会议室的游戏叫《铃铛、波旁与子弹》，一个谋杀之谜晚宴派对游戏。
Yes. We got a lot of mail. People wanted to know is this a real game? Can I buy it? Can I play it? Well, it was a made up game. The box and all the cards and the props inside were created just for our episode. The box and the logos were designed by our new graphic designer, Henry Sane, and Phil
是的。我们收到了很多信件。人们想知道这是个真实的游戏吗？我能买到吗？我能玩吗？好吧，这是一个虚构的游戏。盒子以及里面的所有卡片和道具都是专为我们的剧集制作的。盒子和标志是由我们的新平面设计师亨利·塞恩设计的，还有菲尔
Shea worked with Danny Chun to come up with all of the props and paraphernalia that each character would have. And Randy even shared with us that the box and cards were printed by Phil's go to prop manufacturing company called the Hand Prop Room. Now we know where all this stuff comes from. Well they crushed it. I thought it looked so amazing. I zoomed in on it.
·谢伊与丹尼·陈合作设计了每个角色都会拥有的所有道具和随身物品。兰迪甚至跟我们分享说，盒子和卡片是由菲尔常用的道具制造公司“手持道具室”印刷的。现在我们知道这些东西都是从哪儿来的了。好吧，他们太棒了。我觉得看起来太棒了。我把画面放大了。
I love the catchphrase on the front. What was it? Everything you need to have a deadly good time. Ooh. Ooh. And there was like a fan with blood on it and like a pistol and a glass of bourbon. I love it. Jim is not for this.
我喜欢正面的宣传标语。是什么？你需要度过致命美好时光的一切。哦。哦。还有一个带血的扇子、一把手枪和一杯波旁威士忌。我太喜欢了。吉姆可不赞成这个。
Jim does not want this but Michael's like you owe me one. Tube City. Tube City. Yeah. He shut down Tube City so he owes Michael one. Tube City is a bunch of tubes with a hamster inside that was going to go all over the whole office. We had a fan question from Emmy in Baltimore, Maryland.
吉姆不想这样，但迈克尔觉得你欠我一个人情。管道城。管道城。是的。他关了管道城，所以他欠迈克尔一个人情。管道城是一堆里面有一只仓鼠的管道，它会在整个办公室里跑来跑去。我们收到了来自马里兰州巴尔的摩艾米的粉丝提问。
Who set up Tube City? Phil Shea? Yes, Emmy. Mm-hmm. Yes. And the hamsters were provided by Bob Dunn's Animal Services. Denise Sanders was our hamster wrangler. Greg shared they only had half an hour to shoot the whole B-roll of Tube City.
谁搭建了管道城？菲尔·谢伊？是的，艾米。嗯-hmm。是的。仓鼠是由鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司提供的。丹尼斯·桑德斯是我们的仓鼠管理员。格雷格分享说，他们只有半小时来拍摄管道城的所有花絮镜头。
Oh my God. It's not a lot of time. No. And he said that this whole B-roll idea was kind of an afterthought and so they really didn't have a ton of time to do it. Tube City made me laugh out loud. Laughed so hard. The little hamster and the very endies are just cute little hamster nose coming out of
哦，天哪。时间可真不多。没有。他说这个花絮镜头的想法其实是个事后想法，所以他们真的没有太多时间去做。管道城让我笑出声来。笑得太厉害了。小仓鼠在最后时，它们的小仓鼠鼻子露出了
there. I know. Well, back in the conference room, Michael plays the recording that sets up the whole Murder Mystery game and I am so sorry to say that despite my Googling. Mm-hmm. That you just learned how to do. Mm-hmm. Just a couple years ago.
来。我知道。好吧，回到会议室，迈克尔播放了设定整个谋杀之谜游戏的录音，我非常抱歉地说，尽管我进行了谷歌搜索。嗯-hmm。你刚学会怎么做。嗯-hmm。就在几年前。
Five years ago. And Randy's research, we could not find the name of the person whose voice is on the tape. Anywhere. So listen, if you are the voice of Bell's Bullets and Bourbon, will you let us know? You can write to us at OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com. We'd love to hear from you. Well, this is what the voice on the CD player said.
五年前。还有兰迪的研究，我们找不到磁带上那个声音的主人的名字。任何地方都找不到。所以听着，如果你是《铃铛、子弹与波旁》的声音，你能让我们知道吗？你可以写信给我们，邮箱是OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com。我们很想听到你的消息。好吧，CD机里的声音是这么说的。
Should I do it in an accent? Please. Please, Angela. Okay. Who knows how this is going to go? August the 5th, 1955. It's a sad day down here in Savannah. Local magnet Bill Bourbon was killed last night and all y'all have congregated tonight
我要用口音说吗？请吧。请吧，安吉拉。好吧。谁知道会怎么样呢？1955年8月5日。萨凡纳今天是个悲伤的日子。当地大亨比尔·波旁昨晚被杀，你们所有人都聚集在今晚
for a meal to celebrate Bill as he passes on to his great reward. You're not just here to pay your respects. You have to figure out which of y'all is the no count scoundrel who killed him. That feels good. I'm ready for my dinner theater. You'd be great. You'd love it. It's a lot of improv, Angela.
享用一顿饭，来庆祝比尔走向他伟大的报应。你们不只是来表达敬意的。你们得弄清楚你们当中哪个不争气的无赖杀了人。感觉真好。我准备好去看晚餐剧场了。你会很棒的。你会喜欢的。有很多即兴表演，安吉拉。
I'd have a great time and I also love like vintage costumes. Oh, we got to do one of these, Nifty 50's Murder Mystery Dinner Theater. A special episode of Mom Detective. I mean, God, we just don't have enough time to do it all. Michael starts passing out the character cards and the props. Angela does not like her character. No. We had a fan catch from Katie Kay in San Jose, California.
我会玩得很开心，而且我也喜欢复古服装。哦，我们得做一次这个，摩登50年代谋杀之谜晚餐剧场。妈妈侦探特别集。我是说，天哪，我们实在是没有足够的时间把所有这些都做了。迈克尔开始分发角色卡片和道具。安吉拉不喜欢她的角色。不。我们收到了加利福尼亚州圣何塞市凯蒂·K的粉丝发现。
I think I have a Southern Angela catch. When Angela says I don't like my character at 8 minutes and 54 seconds, Cassie pulled an audio clip. Let's hear it. Michael, I don't like this game. It's scary. It's not scary. I don't like my character.
我想我发现了一个南方安吉拉的梗。当安吉拉在8分54秒说“我不喜欢我的角色”时，卡西截取了一段音频剪辑。我们听听看。迈克尔，我不喜欢这个游戏。这很吓人。这并不吓人。我不喜欢我的角色。
Who are you? Voodoo Mama Juju, the witch doctor of the Savannah Swamps. I'm not comfortable with this. There's so many words that are Southern. I don't like this game. Swamps. I don't like my character. I don't like my character.
你是谁？巫毒妈妈朱朱，萨凡纳沼泽的巫医。我对这个感到不自在。有那么多南方的词汇。我不喜欢这个游戏。沼泽。我不喜欢我的角色。我不喜欢我的角色。
I don't like the game. I don't like my character. It's scary and it's set in a swamp. Yeah. Voodoo Mama Juju. Yep. I hear a hint of it. I don't think it's your strongest accent slip, but I hear a hint.
我不喜欢这个游戏。我不喜欢我的角色。这很吓人，而且背景在沼泽里。是的。巫毒妈妈朱朱。是的。我听出了一点端倪。我不认为这是你最强的口音失误，但我听到了一点。
It's always there, guys. I want to point something out, as we rewatch these episodes, Jenna and I have talked about this. Sometimes we'll just watch a scene and a flood of memories come back that we had totally forgotten about. It's like in a little folder in your brain that hasn't been opened in years. As I watch this scene, when Angela goes to leave and Michael says, there'll be baby carrots and she pivots back to her seat, my skirt is so bunched up.
一直都在，伙计们。我想指出一件事，当我们重温这些剧集时，珍娜和我讨论过这个问题。有时我们只是看一个场景，就会涌现出一堆我们完全忘掉的回忆。就像你大脑里一个好几年没打开过的小文件夹。当我看到这个场景时，当安吉拉要离开，迈克尔说“会有小胡萝卜”时，她转回座位上，我的裙子挤成了一团。
I instantly remembered that this was the week I wanted to wear tights. I was cold. I never wore tights and I wore thick winter tights, but I was wearing a gray pencil skirt that would climb up all day because of the static and the tights. I wrestled that skirt this whole episode. When I watched this moment with the baby carrots, I was like, oh my gosh, that was the week with the skirt that kept crawling up my legs. They used to spray me with static guard.
我立刻想起来，这是我想穿连裤袜的那周。我很冷。我从来不穿连裤袜，我穿了厚厚的冬日连裤袜，但我穿了一条灰色的铅笔裙，由于静电和连裤袜，它整天往上缩。我这一整集都在跟那条裙子较劲。当我看到小胡萝卜这个时刻时，我想，哦天哪，就是那条一直往我腿上爬的裙子的那一周。他们过去常常给我喷防静电喷雾。
Yeah. It didn't matter though because of my tights. Anyway, this is the week I wrestled a skirt. Sometimes those are the things you remember when you rewatch a show. And you know what? We are going to leave no detail unturned in this rewatch. In this oral history that we're creating for all time. We're leaving nothing out.
是的。不过因为我的连裤袜，这根本没用。不管怎样，这是我跟裙子搏斗的一周。有时，这些就是你重温节目时记住的事情。你知道吗？在这场重温中，我们将不放过任何一个细节。在这部我们为后世创作的口述历史中。我们什么都不会落下。
Nothing out. We are going to tell you the week that Jenna's allergies were bad. Yep. We used a bunch. And this is the skirt bunch. This is the skirt bunch. Forever to be known now as the skirt bunch episode. We got a continuity catch from Leah in New Albany, Indiana, who says, I think I have
什么都不落下。我们会告诉你珍娜过敏很严重的那周。是的。我们用了很多纸巾。这就是裙子打团周。这就是裙子打团周。从今以后被称为裙子打团集。我们收到了来自印第安纳州新奥尔巴尼的莉亚的一个连贯性发现，她说，我觉得我有一个
a continuity catch. So you know, Michael gets mad and he takes Oscars Blackberry at 9 minutes 25 seconds. Michael is seen holding it in his hand at 9 minutes 44 seconds. But then at 9 minutes 46 seconds, when Pam stands up to do her character intro, Oscar is looking down again, like maybe he's looking at his Blackberry. And then at 9 minutes 59 seconds, the camera switches angles and you can clearly see that Oscar has his Blackberry back. Good catch.
连贯性发现。所以你知道，迈克尔生气了，他在9分25秒拿走了奥斯卡的黑莓手机。9分44秒时，可以看到迈克尔手里拿着它。但接着在9分46秒，当帕姆站起来做她的角色介绍时，奥斯卡又向下看去了，好像在看他的黑莓手机。然后到了9分59秒，镜头转换角度，你能清楚地看到奥斯卡又拿回了他的黑莓手机。好发现。
I know. I thought that was pretty good. Yeah. Well, speaking of, Pam does offer to go first. And she speaks in an accent to introduce herself as Deb U. Taunt, Deb for short. Then we're going to go through. We're going to meet Andy's character, Nathaniel Nutmeg, and Aaron's character, Naughty Nelly Nutmeg.
我知道。我觉得这挺不错的。是的。说到这里，帕姆主动提出第一个发言。她带着口音自我介绍说是德布·乌·陶特，简称德布。然后我们要继续。我们要见安吉拉的角色、纳撒尼尔·麦芽，还有艾琳的角色、淘气内莉·麦芽。
This is when Andy is very sad to learn that they are brother and sister. Phyllis is Beatrix Bourbon, Michael is successful playboy, Caleb Crawdad, Angela, we know you are voodoo mama juju, well, Danny revealed that he wrote names for the whole cast and Phil created cards for everybody and we didn't get to hear all the names, but he told me what they were. Do you want to hear? I absolutely do. All right.
这时安吉拉非常伤心地得知他们是兄妹。菲利斯是贝atrix·波旁，迈克尔是成功花花公子Caleb Crawdad，安吉拉，我们知道你是巫毒妈妈朱朱，嗯，丹尼透露他为整个剧组写了名字，菲尔为每个人制作了卡片，我们没能听到所有的名字，但他告诉我名字是什么。你想听吗？我绝对想。好吧。
Kevin is Dick Sealand, Oscar is Chad Anuga, Dwight is the butler, Jeeves Julep, Jim is George Apeach, Ryan is Paul Meadow, Meredith is Connie Federit. And then he can't remember who got assigned these characters, but he did have to write two more prop cards and they were Barbie Q and Carl earned greens, earned greens. Like it's a play on collared greens, but it's like Carl earned greens. So those are all the names you didn't hear. Well I did make note of all the props that went with each character. Voodoo mama juju, Angela had a voodoo head and a hat she had to wear.
凯文是Dick Sealand，奥斯卡是Chad Anuga，德怀特是管家Jeeves Julep，吉姆是George Apeach，瑞恩是Paul Meadow，梅雷迪思是Connie Federit。然后他记不清谁被分配了这些角色，但他确实还得写另外两张道具卡，它们是芭比Q（Barbie Q）和卡尔·厄恩·格林斯（Carl earned greens），厄恩·格林斯。就像是对羽衣甘蓝（collard greens）的一个谐音梗，但听起来像卡尔挣了绿叶菜（Carl earned greens）。所以这些就是你没听过的所有名字。不过我确实记下了与每个角色搭配的所有道具。巫毒妈妈朱朱，安吉拉有一个巫毒人头和一个她必须戴的帽子。
I did have a wardrobe fitting for that hat. Somewhere there are photos of me and multiple versions of that hat and that's the one the writers picked. Pam had lace gloves. Yes. Meredith had a long cigarette. Like a cigarette holder. Yes.
我确实为那顶帽子试过装。某个地方有我和那顶帽子的多个版本的照片，那是编剧选中的那个。帕姆有蕾丝手套。是的。梅雷迪思有一根长烟。就像烟嘴一样。是的。
Kevin had a cigar, Phyllis had a feathery fan, Dwight had white butler gloves and it looked like a napkin over his arm, Erin had a lace garter and there was a deleted scene of her putting it on that didn't make it, but you see it ever so slightly at the end when she runs in the conference room. Andy had on men's sleeve garters and I couldn't see what everyone else had, but those were the main ones that were visible. So Andy is going to try to teach Pam how to do a better accent because everyone thinks she just sounds like Forrest Gump and he is able to do like a Florida panhandle accent
凯文有一支雪茄，菲利斯有一把羽毛扇，德怀特有白色的管家手套，他的手臂上看起来搭着一块餐巾，艾琳有一个蕾丝袜带，有一个她正在戴它的被删减片段没能播出来，但在她跑进会议室的最后，你非常微弱地看到了它。安吉拉戴着男士袖箍，我看不清其他人有什么，但这些是主要能看到的道具。所以安吉拉要试着教帕姆怎么说更好的口音，因为每个人都觉得她听起来像阿甘正传，而他能模仿佛罗里达狭长地带的口音
and then he gets into his description of a Savannah accent where he says it's like, it's coming out of your mouth. It's so good. Danny said they were originally planning for Andy to have a horrible accent, but on the day they realized that Ed was very good at these different accents and so they rewrote it. Well, he is from Georgia and he probably has a good ear for all the accents there. Interestingly enough, there was an Andy talking head in the shooting draft that did not make
然后他开始描述萨凡纳的口音，他说那听起来就像是从你嘴里冒出来的。太棒了。丹尼说他们原本计划让安吉拉有一个糟糕的口音，但在当天他们意识到埃德非常擅长这些不同的口音，于是他们重写了。好吧，他是佐治亚州人，他可能对那里的所有口音都有一双好耳朵。有趣的是，拍摄初稿中有一个安吉拉的单人采访没有被采用
it. This is what it said. I went to dialect camp every summer from the age seven to 18. And I was a counselor for 10 years. What? It was Andy's childhood. So we learned in the meeting that he spent a summer in Toulouse apprenticing for a formagerie. Now we find out that he went to a dialect camp for years.
它是这么说的。我从7岁到18岁每年夏天都去方言夏令营。我当了10年辅导员。什么？那是安吉拉的童年。所以我们在会议上得知他在图卢兹度过了一个夏天，在一家奶酪店当学徒。现在我们发现他去方言夏令营好多年。
Well it's interesting, Angela, because we have wondered if deleted scenes count. If something doesn't make it into an episode, does it still count in that character's lore in the story? Right. And sort of in the canon of the show, is it part of that? And we sort of said, no, no. It's what aired. Yes, that is what would be the show Bible.
好吧，这很有趣，安吉拉，因为我们一直在想被删减的场景算不算数。如果有什么东西没有进入一集节目，它还算不算该角色在故事中的背景设定的一部分？对的。在节目的正统设定中，它是其中一部分吗？我们有点说过，不算不算。播出的才算。是的，那才会是剧集圣经。
Well, I found an old article on OfficeTally.com from 2007. Right when Google started. Right. There was an interview with Greg Daniels. He talked about this? Yes. What did he say? He said, quote, for the writers in our minds, those scenes have happened.
好吧，我在OfficeTally.com上找到了一篇2007年的老文章。就在谷歌刚开始的时候。对。里面有对格雷格·丹尼尔斯的采访。他谈到这个了？是的。他说什么了？他说，引述：“对于编剧们来说，在我们心中，那些场景已经发生了。
We wrote them, we shot them, and at the last minute, I cut them in the editing room. But we're relying on them anyway for the mythology of the show. Wow. Okay. So per Greg, if it made it in the shooting draft. If we shot it, then it's part of the mythology of the show. So that would mean that, yes, Andy did spend a summer as a fromager. He did do this weird accent camp.
我们写了它们，我们拍摄了它们，然后在最后一分钟，我在剪辑室里把它们剪掉了。但为了节目的神话体系，我们无论如何都会依赖它们。”哇。好吧。所以根据格雷格的说法，如果它进入了拍摄初稿。如果我们拍了它，那么它就是节目神话体系的一部分。那这就意味着，是的，安吉拉确实当了一个夏天的奶酪学徒。他确实参加了这个奇怪的方言夏令营。
But here is the problem. The exception that proves the rule would be Pam's painting. Because Pam's painting, they shot it being destroyed, it stayed off the wall for several episodes. It's still off the wall in this episode. In this episode, there's still just golfing inspiration, but it came back. So I don't know. I think it's still up for debate, Greg.
但问题来了。证明规则的例外将是帕姆的画。因为帕姆的画，他们拍了它被毁掉的镜头，它有几集没有挂在墙上。在这一集中它仍然没挂在墙上。在这集中，仍然只有高尔夫灵感，但它后来回来了。所以我不确定。我认为这仍然有待商榷，格雷格。
Sorry, Greg. We don't know. This interview does predate the destruction of the painting. So he's allowed to change his mind on that one. People are pretty impressed by Andy's accents. Kevin has a request, the sweetest chef. He's like, what province is he from? And Kevin says, he lives on Sesame Street, dumbass.
对不起，格雷格。我们不知道。这个采访确实早于画作被毁的时间。所以他可以改变对那个的主意。人们对安吉拉的口音印象相当深刻。凯文有一个要求，最甜的厨师。他说，他是哪个省的？凯文说，他住在芝麻街，个笨蛋。
This got such a huge laugh at the table read, like people lost their minds. And when the final edit of the episode came and Greg saw it, it wasn't in. It got cut. Really? And Greg was like, where's Kevin's line about Sesame Street? He absolutely loved this line. And Greg fought really hard to have it put back in. Well, I'll have you know, Stephanie M. from Salt Lake City, Utah, would like to point
这在剧本围读时引来了一场大笑，人们简直笑疯了。当这集的最终剪辑完成，格雷格看到它时，这一段不在里面。被剪掉了。真的吗？格雷格当时就问，凯文关于芝麻街的台词呢？他绝对爱惨了这句台词。格雷格费了好大劲才把它加回去。
out that the sweetest chef does not live on Sesame Street. He's from the Muppet Show. Yes. Which makes the line even funnier. Yes. Well, why don't we take a break? Because when we come back, I need to point out a line that Phyllis could not say. Ooh.
好吧，我得告诉你，来自犹他州盐湖城的斯蒂芬妮·M想指出，最甜的厨师不住在芝麻街。他是《布偶秀》里的。是的。这让这句台词更搞笑了。是的。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？因为等我们回来时，我需要指出一句菲利斯怎么也说不对的台词。哦。
And I have some things to say about Creed. We'll be back. We are back, and as you guys rewatch this episode with us, please go to the conference room scene where Phyllis has to say, I overheard you ask in the butler where the pistol was kept. Okay. Jenna, do you remember every time Phyllis got to the word pistol? She started to snicker, and we all started to break.
而且我有一些关于克里德的话要说。我们马上回来。我们回来了，当你们和我们一起重温这一集时，请转到会议室的场景，菲利斯必须说：“我无意中听到你问管家手枪放在哪儿了。”好吧。珍娜，你还记得菲利斯每次说到“手枪”这个词的时候吗？她就开始咯咯笑，我们大家都开始笑场了。
No. If you listen to it, she says, pistol, because she can barely get through that word. We got tickled every single time. Oh my gosh. Now that you say it, I remember that. That would happen with Phyllis in general, too. Yeah. It was everything.
不。如果你仔细听，她说的是“手枪”，因为她几乎说不完这个词。我们每一次都被逗乐了。哦天哪。经你这么一说，我记起来了。菲利斯平时也会这样。是的。什么都行。
It was the Southern accent. She had to be doing the fan. And then when she said pistol, it made me laugh. I remembered instantly how tickled we got. Well, guys, Creed is going to arrive to work. He's late. He's sorry. Yeah.
就是南方口音。她还得拿着扇子。然后当她说“手枪”时，把我逗笑了。我立刻想起了我们当时被逗得有多开心。好吧，伙计们，克里德要来上班了。他迟到了。他很抱歉。是的。
He asked Michael what's going on. And Michael says, as Caleb crawdad, there's been a murder, and you're a suspect. And Creed is like, oh, okay, great. Can I just have a- Let me get settled. I'll be right back. I'll be right back. And he just hightails it right out of there.
他问迈克尔发生了什么事。迈克尔以Caleb Crawdad的身份说，发生了一起谋杀案，你是嫌疑人。克里德就说，哦，好吧，太棒了。我能先——让我安顿一下。我马上回来。我马上回来。然后他一溜烟地跑出去了。
Now, some people on some message boards think that this is an indication that Creed is the Scranton Strangler. Oh. Mm-hmm. Sorry. That reaction was like a cartoon. Oh. I do declare.
现在，一些论坛上的一些人认为这表明克里德就是斯克兰顿扼杀者。哦。嗯-hmm。抱歉。那个反应就像个动画片。哦。我敢发誓。
Yes. My goodness. However, I will say this. We see Creed leave. We see him jump into a car. I was like, oh, I think this is our first time seeing Creed's car. I even asked Randy about it. He said that our transportation coordinator, Jesse Dutchover, rented that car from Cinema
是的。天哪。不过，我要这么说。我们看到克里德离开。我们看到他跳上一辆车。我想，哦，我想这是我们第一次看到克里德的车。我甚至还问了兰迪关于这辆车的事。他说我们的交通协调员杰西·达乔弗从电影
Vehicle Services. It is a picture car. That means cars that are rented out to productions to be in movies and TV. And that the rental facility was just a few blocks away. And we established this as Creed's car. And whenever we needed to see Creed in his car, this was the car they rented from this facility. And til he drove a Porsche years later.
车辆服务公司租了那辆车。这是一辆道具车。这意味着那些租给制作组用于电影和电视的车辆。而且租赁设施就在几个街区之外。我们将这定为克里德的车。每当我们需要看到克里德坐在他的车里时，这就是他们从这个设施租的车。直到他几年后开了一辆保时捷。
Correct. But in the future, when we see news footage of the police chasing who they think might be the Scranton Strangler, look at the car. Oh. It is not the car that Creed jumps into right here. Now, does Creed have many cars at his disposal after his work as the Scranton Strangler? Probably yes, but I did just want to point out that there's a little bit of a car thing going on.
没错。但在未来，当我们看到警察追捕他们认为是斯克兰顿扼杀者的嫌疑人的新闻画面时，看看那辆车。哦。那不是克里德在这里跳上去的那辆车。现在，克里德在作为斯克兰顿扼杀者作案后，手头会有很多车吗？可能是的，但我只是想指出这里有点关于车的小问题。
I mean, Creed also, we have found out lives under his desk and has a home in Canada. So anything can happen with Creed. I have some things to share as well. Greg said that Creed running to his car was actually a lot harder to shoot than it looks. Really? First of all, the timing of it. I mean, Creed had to really book it. He had to run to the car.
我是说，我们还发现克里德住在他的办公桌底下，在加拿大还有一个家。所以克里德身上什么都有可能发生。我也有一些事情要分享。格雷格说，克里德跑向他的车实际上比看起来要难拍得多。真的吗？首先，时机。我是说，克里德真的得全力冲刺。他必须跑到车那儿。
He had to jump in and then doing this back out and pull out move with a car as big as a Lincoln Town car, which is what it is, was not easy. So this quick little moment actually took a little bit of planning. And lady, it's at this moment, I realized that Creed the character and me in real life have a little something in common. What's that? We have both driven Lincoln Town cars. Oh, you had a Lincoln Town car once?
他必须跳进去，然后开着一辆像林肯城市轿车这么大的车做倒车和驶出的动作，这可不容易。所以这个简短的小时刻实际上需要不少规划。而女士们，正是在这个时刻，我意识到角色克里德和我现实中的生活有一点点共同之处。什么共同点？我们都开过林肯城市轿车。哦，你曾经有一辆林肯城市轿车？
My grandmother's car was a green Lincoln Town car with a white top and my grandmother's who taught me how to drive because in the summers I would go stay with my grandparents for a visit. And when I was turning 16, she took me out in her enormous Lincoln Town car. And that's what I learned to drive a car in. Wow. You know, I learned how to drive in an enormous car as well. What was the enormous car?
我祖母的车是一辆绿色的林肯城市轿车，配有白色的车顶，是我祖母教我开车的，因为夏天我会去祖父母家小住。当我16岁生日时，她带着我开她那辆巨大的林肯城市轿车出去了。我就是在那辆车里学会开车的。哇。你知道的，我也是在一辆巨大的车里学会开车的。是什么巨大的车？
It was a 1978 Pontiac Catalina. Hey. That was a big long car. That was a big long car. My grandmother had pedal extenders. So that was good. So I wasn't right up on the steering wheel. You sort of had to learn in your grandmother's car.
是一辆1978年的庞蒂亚克卡特琳娜。嘿。那是一辆又长又大的车。那是一辆又长又大的车。我祖母有加长踏板。所以那挺好的。这样我就不会紧贴着方向盘了。你有点像是在你祖母的车里学会开车的。
Why? Because I'm short? Well, yeah, those pedal extenders really helped you out. They were very helpful. Apparently, I made my mom stressed out when she rode with me to teach me how to drive. So she gave it to your grandma. My dad was like, I'm not getting in the car with her. So my grandmother said, I'll teach her to drive.
为什么？因为我很矮吗？嗯，是的，那些加长踏板确实帮了你大忙。它们非常有用。显然，当我妈妈陪着我教我开车时，我让她感到压力很大。所以她把它交给了你奶奶。我爸爸说：“我才不跟她上一辆车呢。”所以我的祖母说：“我来教她开车。”
And she did. Well, as your BFF who's ridden in many cars with you, you're a great driver. Thank you. Yeah. No pedal extenders anymore either. The seat goes all the way up. Although I wouldn't mind. Really?
她确实这么做了。好吧，作为和你一起坐过很多次车的闺蜜，你是个很棒的司机。谢谢。是的。现在也没有加长踏板了。座位可以完全推到最前面。虽然我不介意。真的吗？
Yeah. Because then you're not so close to the steering wheel. Yeah. So now we have a little romance in the kitchen. Andy and Erin, they're chatting. They're still doing their accents. But he asks her out on a date and she says yes. But then later in the conference room, other people start asking her out on a date and
对。因为那样你就不会离方向盘那么近了。是的。现在我们在厨房里有一段小小的浪漫。安吉拉和艾琳，他们在聊天。他们还在用他们的口音。但他约她出去约会，她答应了。但后来在会议室里，其他人开始约她出去约会，
she's saying yes. And then Andy is like, oh, wait, was she just in character in the kitchen? Yeah, did I? Or are we really going on a date? Did I ask out Naughty Nelly or did I ask out Erin? Well in the conference room at 12 minutes 36 seconds, there is a really good shot of Kevin's character card where you can very plainly see that his name is Dixieland. And he's also has an extra prop in this scene.
她也都答应了。然后安吉拉就想，哦等等，她刚才在厨房里只是在角色扮演吗？是的，我是吗？还是我们真的要去约会？我约的是淘气内莉还是艾琳？好吧，在12分36秒的会议室里，有一个非常清晰的凯文角色特写镜头，你能非常明显地看到他的名字叫Dixieland。而且他在这一场戏中还有一个额外的道具。
He's got a lot of money. Oh yes, it's said in the script that he was one of the richest men in all of Savannah. Yeah. Well, so much so that he walks around carrying a lot of money. Oscar interrupts the game. He shares that he received an email from corporate instructing the accounting department to stop all payments to vendors. Wow.
他有很多钱。哦是的，剧本里说他是萨凡纳最富有的人之一。是的。富到他到处走动时都带着一大笔钱。奥斯卡打断了游戏。他分享说他收到了一封来自总部的电子邮件，指示会计部门停止向所有供应商付款。哇。
That's serious. Yeah. Well, Michael insists that Oscar give no more details unless he is speaking in character. Yeah. He does not use his Yankee accent, Michael says. So Oscar tries to give important news about the company as a Southern character. We got mail. Mm-hmm.
这很严重。是的。好吧，迈克尔坚持要求奥斯卡除非用角色的口音说话，否则不准透露更多细节。是的。迈克尔说，他不能用他的北方口音。所以奥斯卡试图用南方口音提供关于公司的重要新闻。我们有信了。嗯-hmm。
Fan mail flurry on this one. Starting with Zach M. from Venice Center, New York. Does Oscar struggle with a Southern accent in real life or was this just more of his brilliant acting? Zach, it was just brilliant acting. 100% amazing acting job by Oscar. We did about six takes of this and Danny Chun spoke about this in an interview with office telly.com.
这一集的粉丝来信狂潮。从纽约威尼斯中心的扎克·M开始。奥斯卡在现实生活中很难掌握南方口音，还是这只是他精湛演技的一部分？扎克，这只是精湛的演技。奥斯卡100%惊人的演技。我们拍了大约六条，丹尼·陈在接受office telly.com采访时谈到了这一点。
He reminded me that at first, Oscar was doing a really deep voice and it was the last take where he did the super high voice that we used in the show. None of us were expecting it. We had gotten used to his low voice Southern accent. That's right. We had a fan question from Jenny F. in Amarillo, Texas and many others who wanted to know how did we keep a straight face during this scene? Oh, we did not.
他提醒我，起初，奥斯卡的声音用得很低沉，最后一条时他用了我们在节目中使用的超高音调。我们都没有预料到。我们已经习惯了他低沉声音的南方口音。没错。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州阿马里洛的珍妮·F以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道我们在这一幕中是如何保持严肃不笑场的？哦，我们根本没有。
No. Especially not on that last take. Not the one you see. No. When he came in in that higher falsetto and he's talking about the green bat, we were on the floor. Even Steve broke and Steve never breaks. It made it onto the season six bloopers.
没有。特别是最后那一条。绝对不是你看到的那个。不。当他用那种较高的假声进来，谈论绿背钞票时，我们都笑趴在地上。就连史蒂夫也笑场了，而史蒂夫从不笑场。这被剪进了第六季的笑场集锦中。
I asked Cassie to pull it so we could hear it. This here plantation is running low on green backs. We ain't got no money to pay the people who sell us the seeds and dirt. I can't do this, Michael. Basically. You can sort of hear Steve, I can recognize everybody's different laugh. I do too. I hear John.
我让卡西把它调出来，这样我们就能听到。我们这片种植园的绿背钞票快用完了。我们没有钱付给卖给我们种子和泥土的人。我做不下去了，迈克尔。基本上。你隐约能听到史蒂夫的声音，我能认出每个人的不同笑声。我也能。我听到约翰的声音。
I hear definitely Brian and Steve. Oh yeah. Man, I rewatched the bloopers for that as well. From the camera angle from our backs, my head is just bent over. I'm bent over. I have to say, whenever Oscar and Steve were paired together in a scene, I don't know what it was. I think because they were the two that never broke, they got each other.
我绝对听到了布莱恩和史蒂夫的声音。哦，是的。天哪，我也重温了那一集的笑场花絮。从我们身后的摄像机角度来看，我的头完全弯下去了。我弯着身子。我必须说，每当奥斯卡和史蒂夫在戏里搭档时，我不知道是怎么回事。我想是因为他们俩是从来不笑场的演员，他们彼此合拍。
They really did. Yeah. I wish there were more Oscar-Michael moments. In rewatching, I'm like, gosh, man, I really wish that Oscar had to do a sales call with Michael or something. Well, I know there's some good ones coming up. Oh yeah. This news from Oscar really bumps people out and they go back to work.
他们确实很合拍。是的。我希望有更多奥斯卡和迈克尔的对手戏。在重温时，我想，天哪，我真的很希望奥斯卡不得不和迈克尔一起去拜访客户或者干点别的。好吧，我知道接下来会有一些精彩的。哦，是的。奥斯卡的消息真的让大家很难过，他们又回去工作了。
Also, the murderers revealed on the tape. It was Phyllis. And she was really bummed because she felt like she was doing a good job. Yeah. Andy wants to figure out if he asked Aaron out or if he asked out Naughty Nelly. Right. So they have this great scene of front reception. I thought Ed and Ellie did such a great job just playing two people who like each other
此外，磁带里揭晓了凶手。是菲利斯。她真的很沮丧，因为她觉得自己做得很好。是的。安吉拉想弄清楚他到底是约了艾琳还是约了淘气内莉。对。所以他们在前台有一场非常棒的戏。我觉得埃德和艾丽把两个互相喜欢却又不敢承认的人演得太好了。
but are afraid to admit it. I agree. It ultimately ends up that neither of them admit that it was real when it was real for both of them. Yeah. So it's not going to happen yet, but we are solidifying the information that they're into each other. Michael insists the game isn't over.
我同意。最终结果是，当这对彼此都是真心的时候，他们谁都没有承认那是真的。是的。所以这还不会发生，但我们正在巩固他们对彼此有感觉的信息。迈克尔坚称游戏还没结束。
He is now, I think he's in a full spiral. He will not break character. Danny talked about this and the challenge of writing for Michael when Michael isn't his true self. Oh. He said he had to write for Michael as Caleb crawdad. And Greg compared this episode to grief counseling when Michael was unaware of what was motivating him and the episode was playing out in his subconscious and he said this episode is a
他现在，我觉得他完全陷入了失控状态。他绝不出戏。丹尼谈到了这一点，以及当迈克尔不是真实的自己时为迈克尔写剧本的挑战。哦。他说他必须把迈克尔当作Caleb Crawdad来写。格雷格把这一集比作悲伤辅导，当时的迈克尔并没有意识到是什么在激励着他，这一集是在他的潜意识中进行的，他说这一集是一个
variation of that where Michael is not sure what's motivating him, but he's locked into this character. That's really interesting. You know, Pam and Jim are going to have a talking head where they asked the question, has Michael snapped? Is he stuck in character? What's going on? I noticed something in this talking head.
变体，迈克尔不确定是什么在激励着他，但他完全锁定在这个角色里了。这真的很有趣。你知道，帕姆和吉姆将有一场单人采访，他们提出了这个问题：迈克尔崩溃了吗？他被困在角色里了吗？怎么回事？我在这个单人采访中注意到了一件事。
What? I am wearing the same outfit that I wore in double date, which was last week's episode. It's exactly the same. I kind of noticed it earlier in the episode, but this talking head solidified it for me. Yeah. Now that you say it, it's the exact same outfit. It's that very kind of dark gray shirt with that lighter gray blazer. Yes.
什么？我穿着我在《双重约会》中穿的同一套衣服，那是上一集的戏。完全一模一样。我在这集前面就有点注意到了，但这单人采访为我证实了这一点。是的。经你这么一说，这完全是同一套衣服。就是那种非常深灰色的衬衫配浅灰色西装外套。是的。
Thank you. I was trying to get the words. The only thing that's different is that in double date, I'm wearing some little hoop earrings that I'm not wearing in this episode. I tried to figure out how did this happen? Why would Alicia put the same outfit in my trailer on back to back weeks? Well, she didn't. I have a mom detectives moment.
谢谢。我刚才正想找这个词。唯一不同的是，在《双重约会》中，我戴了一些小耳环，而这一集我没戴。我一直在琢磨这到底是怎么发生的？为什么艾丽西亚会连续两周在我的房车里放同一套衣服？好吧，她没有。我有一个妈妈侦探时刻。
What? What'd you find out? I found out that we filmed these episodes in a different order than they aired. We originally filmed double date, then Koi pond, then murder. Oh. So there was a week in between. They aired as Koi pond first, then double date, then murder. So I had gone up to the bigger belly bump, the belly B, and it was only meant for these
什么？你发现了什么？我发现我们拍摄这些剧集的顺序和播出的顺序不一样。我们最初拍摄的是《双重约会》，然后是《锦鲤池》，然后是《谋杀》。哦。所以中间隔了一周。它们播出的顺序是先《锦鲤池》，然后《双重约会》，然后《谋杀》。所以我已经换上了更大的孕肚假体，即B号假体，它只打算用于这
three episodes. And we had to tailor the clothes to the bump. So I think Alicia was trying to get a little extra mileage out of my B bump wardrobe. And she thought, well, as long as I throw an episode in between, we won't notice that Pam has recycled this outfit, but then they ended up airing back to back. So Pam's in the same clothes. Two weeks in a row. Good mom detective catch.
三集。我们不得不根据假体来修改衣服。所以我猜艾丽西亚是想从我的孕肚假体衣橱里榨取一点额外的价值。她想，好吧，只要我在中间插播一集，我们就不会注意到帕姆循环穿了这套衣服，但后来它们连续播出了。所以帕姆穿着同样的衣服。连续两周。好一个妈妈侦探的发现。
Thank you. You know, Dunder Mifflin Closing is really going to hit Pam and Jim hard. They both work there. They're married and both working at the same company. And expecting a baby. With a baby on the way. Yes. I know.
谢谢。你知道的，邓德米夫林的倒闭真的会给帕姆和吉姆沉重一击。他们俩都在那儿工作。他们结婚了，而且在同一家公司工作。还有一个即将出生的孩子。还有一个即将出生的孩子。是的。我知道。
And they're talking about that in Jim's office when Michael busts in and he's like, come on, Deb, we need you. We need you. And Pam goes. That's 17 minutes, two seconds, if you're curious what is splattered on the floor by Meredith's head, that's roast beef. It's from the little lunch platter that is there on the table. You can see all the roast beef has been placed on the floor.
他们在吉姆的办公室里谈论这个时，迈克尔突然闯进来，他说：“来吧，德布，我们需要你。我们需要你。”帕姆去了。如果对梅雷迪思头旁边地板上溅的是什么好奇的话，那是17分2秒，那是烤牛肉。那是桌上那个小午餐拼盘里的。你能看到所有的烤牛肉都被放在了地板上。
Jim has really lost his patience at this point. And he demands to speak to Michael and Michael snaps back at him so hard. He's like, you shut up. Yeah. And we have one of those drama moments. Here's the thing. We've been wondering is Michael losing it? Has he gone crazy?
吉姆此时真的失去了耐心。他要求跟迈克尔说话，而迈克尔极其严厉地顶撞了他。他说：“你闭嘴。”是的。我们迎来了那种戏剧性时刻之一。事情是这样的。我们一直在想，迈克尔是不是失控了？他疯了吗？
And here's where you realize he's actually quite lucid. And this is a choice. He is choosing to lose himself and help the office lose themselves in this game. Yep. It is a strategy. During all of this, David Wallace finally calls back. Jim takes the call. I thought Andy Buckley did such a great job because you can just hear how distracted slash
而正是在这里，你意识到他其实非常清醒。这是一个选择。他选择让自己迷失，并帮助办公室里的其他人在这场游戏里迷失自我。是的。这是一个策略。正当这一切发生时，大卫·华莱士终于回电话了。吉姆接了电话。我觉得安迪·巴克利演得太棒了，因为你能听出他有多分心
worried slash trying to like put out a bunch of fires like his day, you know? Yeah. Yeah. He was just sitting back in the annex at Kelly's desk making this phone call in real life. That's where he was. Well, everyone knows that Jim has just taken this call and they're so anxious about what he's going to say.
、多担忧、多想试图扑灭一堆火，就像他的一天那样，你知道吗？是的。是的。他当时就坐在 annex 里凯利的办公桌旁打这个电话，在现实生活中。他当时就在那儿。好吧，大家都知道吉姆刚刚接了这个电话，他们对于他会说些什么感到无比焦虑。
And there's no really anything good to say and so Jim decides to join Michael and he's like, turns out there's been another murder. And the look on Michael's face of like, oh, thank God, he's with me. Well, I love their talking head. Michael has this line that rang so true to me. He says, today is the hardest I've worked in a long, long time. That was a pitch from Steve. Yeah.
而且真的没有什么好消息可说，于是吉姆决定加入迈克尔，他说：“原来又发生了一起谋杀案。”迈克尔脸上的表情仿佛在说：“哦，谢天哪，他和我在同一阵线。”好吧，我喜欢他们的单人采访。迈克尔有一句台词让我深有同感。他说：“今天是我很长很长一段时间以来工作最辛苦的一天。”那是史蒂夫即兴发挥的提议。是的。
It's good. It's so good. I didn't know that he pitched that. Yeah. I mean, I also just thought of how hard Steve worked this week. Yeah. Like, that was a hard week. Yeah.
太棒了。太棒了。我不知道那是他提出来的。是的。我的意思是，我也想到了史蒂夫这周工作有多努力。是的。那真是辛苦的一周。是的。
Well, now Andy, Michael and Dwight are in a three-way standoff with like finger guns. Mm-hmm. They're like pointed at each other. Mm-hmm. I guess Jim shares that Andy revealed himself to be a double agent and then so was Dwight and as it turns out, so was Michael. So it's six o'clock and Jim would really like to go home. Yeah.
好吧，现在安吉拉、迈克尔和德怀特陷入了一场三方对峙，用着手指枪。嗯-hmm。他们用手指指着对方。嗯-hmm。我猜吉姆透露安吉拉暴露了自己是个双重间谍，然后德怀特也是，结果证明，迈克尔也是。所以现在是六点钟，吉姆真的很想回家。是的。
But guess who he needs to get out of the conference room? Pam is part of this standoff. She is. Her finger guns are drawn as well. And she says to Jim, grab the keys, start the car. She's going to slowly back out of the conference room. And then the three-way standoff turns into a dramatic shootout. Everyone's writhing on the floor.
但你猜他需要把谁从会议室里弄出去？帕姆也是这场对峙的一部分。她是。她的手指枪也拔出来了。她对吉姆说：“拿上钥匙，发动汽车。”她要慢慢地退出了会议室。然后这场三方对峙变成了一场戏剧性的枪战。每个人都在地板上痛苦地扭动。
We had a fan question from Caroline P. in Honolulu, Hawaii for the tag at the end. How much of that scene was scripted and how much of it was just Steve, Ed and Rain improvising and having fun with it? Well, tell you what. In the script, it ends with Pam backing out of the conference room. It was supposed to just end on a standoff. Yeah. And then on the day, they started doing the shootout, all shooting each other.
我们收到了来自夏威夷檀香山的卡罗琳·P的粉丝提问，针对结尾的彩蛋。那个场景有多少是按剧本演的，又有多少是史蒂夫、埃德和雷恩即兴发挥并乐在其中的？好吧，我告诉你。在剧本中，结局是帕姆退出会议室。本该在对峙中就结束的。是的。然后在当天，他们开始进行枪战，互相射击。
And this is how it ended up being. Greg shared that when the guys fell on the ground and were like convulsing and everything, that was just them. They were just having fun. He said it was like little kids getting to play. Yeah. It looked like it. It did.
结果就成了现在这个样子。格雷格分享说，当这几个家伙倒在地上抽搐和做各种动作时，那完全是他们自己发挥的。他们只是在玩得很开心。他说那就像小孩子在玩耍一样。是的。看起来确实如此。确实如此。
Well, at 20 minutes, 44 seconds, I wanted to point out one thing. The reveal of Pam is so great. And Greg shared what really made that happen was our camera operator, Matt Zone. His ability to whip around in a circle like that is what really captured the moment. Matt and Randall were so amazing. So whenever we can give a shout out to them, way to go, Matt Zone. We got another fan question from Patricia B. in Oklahoma who said, Jenna, how much did you enjoy that final scene when you were in the conference room doing your finger guns
好吧，在20分44秒，我想指出一件事。帕姆的登场太棒了。格雷格分享说，真正促成这一幕的是我们的摄像师马特·佐恩。他能够以那样的方式转着圈甩动镜头的技巧，正是真正捕捉到那个时刻的原因。马特和兰德尔太棒了。所以无论何时我们能向他们大声致敬，干得好，马特·佐恩。我们收到了来自俄克拉荷马州的帕特里夏·B的另一个粉丝提问，她说：“珍娜，当你身处会议室用手指枪进行对峙时，你有多喜欢那场最后的戏？”
standoff? It was so fun. And it's like a very popular meme of me, you know, that says, I'm not going down for this. Yeah. That line. It was so funny. I remember the direction from Greg was like, you need to act like you are 100% invested
太好玩了。而且那就像是我一个非常受欢迎的表情包，你知道的，上面写着：“我才不会为此认输呢。”是的。那句台词。太搞笑了。我记得格雷格的指导是：“你需要表现得好像你100%投入到了
in this. Like this is real in your mind. You have to get out. You have to get out and you're going to get out safe. Yeah. I was like, all right, let's do it. And you got to be in a mini action movie. I did.
这件事中。”就像在你的脑海里这是真的一样。你必须出去。你必须出去，而且你会安全地出去。是的。我说，好的，我们干吧。然后你还能参演一部迷你动作片。我确实演了。
Well, there you have it. That is murder. I want to give a big thank you to Danny Chun for all of his details. He said you can find him at Danny Chun on Twitter. He's got a bunch of fun stuff coming up, but he said it's going to be a while, not till the summer, but we'll post all about it when it's there. Well, of course, we always want to give a big shout out and lots of love to Randy Cordray every week answering our questions, we love you, Randy.
好吧，这就是全部内容。这就是《谋杀》。我要向丹尼·陈提供所有的细节表示诚挚的谢意。他说你可以在推特上找到他，用户名是Danny Chun。他有很多有趣的东西即将推出，但他说还要过一段时间，要到夏天，不过等有了我们会在那儿发布所有相关消息。当然，我们每周都要向兰迪·库德瑞表达我们巨大的敬意和满满的爱，感谢他回答我们的问题，我们爱您，兰迪。
All right, you guys, well, we're taking next week off for spring break, but we'll be back the week after with shareholder meeting. Oh, that's the recyclops. Oh, yeah. And I am already trading emails with our costume designer, Alicia Raycraft, to get all the details on that recyclops costume transformation. I can't wait. You guys have a great one.
好了，大家，我们下周要放春假，不过两周后我们会带着股东大会的内容回来。哦，那是“回收怪杰”。哦，对的。而且我已经开始和我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特（Alicia Raycraft）发邮件沟通“回收怪杰”服装变身的细节了。我等不及了。大家过个好假期。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Stitcher Premium享受免费一个月的试用，请使用优惠码：Office。这集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。